what do you think of artists who wait
for other people to teach them how to be
an artist
I don't think you should wait for
anything I I always had a strong sense
that I had something to say even as a
little kid I don't know if it was
because I was like the youngest of four
but I was like everybody listen to me
and so I started writing songs very
young so I was like I can do this you
know and I just like have always barged
into situations where I'm like I want to
paint or I want to draw or I want to
sing and made it happen and so when it
came
to any Cree I like and people are always
like well what's the difference between
doing music or doing filming there is no
difference to me creatively it's just
how I'm saying it and it's never been
about like I need to learn something
first it's like I'll learn as I go and I
think that has made it so I actually
have output because if you wait around
to know everything you're never going to
release anything and like only once you
release something do you learn what you
can do better next time
and why don't you like to wait
I don't know if it's just I'm an
impatient person you know like
um I've just never depended on anybody
to show me the right way to do something
um
yeah it's just I'm ready to barge in
always jump in feet first and and then
see what the consequences are
you're a fast learner yeah okay I think
fast learner says they don't like to
wait because they usually grasp things
fairly oh yeah yeah you only need to
show me something once and so like with
camera like I started as an AC just for
friends of mine and like watch what they
did watch where they Place camera watch
what lenses they used and that's how I
learned how to shoot
um same thing with when I got into film
I got into film through music and so we
worked with directors the first couple
times we wanted to do music videos and
again like you know I was in there in
their notes doing all their help in
their pre-production and seeing where I
could pull you know any help I could for
them and in that process basically
learned how to do pre-production on a
production and then I was like well I
can't afford to hire director every time
so I'm just gonna start doing it
um and I think that was also part of why
I don't wait around because I can't
afford to like hire people so it's like
well if I can get like a 500 camera and
I can go now that I have this knowledge
I'll just go do it myself
um so I think that's always been part of
it too it's like what can I do myself to
get this done
you said in the past that you charge in
where sometimes maybe you don't belong
or you just like to just go for it can
you give us examples
yeah well like with film you know coming
from music a lot of people are like oh
you've got to go to film school you got
to learn all this stuff and I just like
never felt like that was for me like I'm
not gonna go to school for four years
before I decide if I'm gonna go do
something so it's definitely like let's
just go make a feature and when we made
our first feature a few of our friends
that went to film School were like you
need to stop you know I just you're no
good just stop now but yeah we didn't
listen to them we're like okay well
we'll just do another one we'll be
better next time
um so definitely I've gotten that kind
of feedback and as a woman in the
industry you always get that kind of
feedback like you know I was uh AC on
one thing once and I was just filling in
for a couple weeks and I overheard the
DP tell the camera operator like oh
we'll get you a guy next time don't
worry about it and I was like well what
what is that about you know like he was
just so annoyed to have a woman on set
with him you know so definitely you know
I don't let that stuff really get to me
because I'll just go to the next set and
it'll be different hopefully
um but yeah definitely you know there's
always Clicks in every industry and
music and film wherever
um and you gotta break in you know or
find your own people to make your own
little circle around that you can have
that kind of collaboration that's going
to make something good
do you think in some ways it's good that
you didn't go to film school because you
weren't trained to do sort of like
Cookie Cutter things you found like a
more interesting path
yeah I think for me like going back to
being an artist like it's like you know
I like the weirder stuff I like weird
lighting I like you know not straight
three section narratives you know I like
it to go to different places and and
like I like it to be surprising you know
like I don't want to do the same movie
we've seen a thousand times you know in
some ways I think that makes our movies
harder to like gain acceptance because
they are a little bit out there like the
sense of humor is a little off or
whatever but I think in the long run
it'll show the body of work has like
this immature type brain you know behind
everything and I'm not sure if that
would have been beaten out of me if I'm
like oh I must do it the proper way you
know this three-act structure like
without you know not mixing humor with
drama and stuff like that like
um I definitely like it's a lot of
freedom to like not knowing the right
way to do it and of course you pick it
up as you go along because like there
are standards for a reason like and how
to shoot you know you got your wide your
medium you're close like that's their
there for a reason you know so make an
edit make sense so you have to pick up a
certain base level I think
um but yeah maybe it's better not
sometimes you know not to have like you
must do this way in these boxes
do you see everybody that you know that
went to film School actually working in
the film industry
um
I'm not sure yeah because I definitely
know a lot of people that have gone and
what I have seen for some people it's
been really good is more the connections
that they've made you know so like you
know they all went to this college and
so they all still work on each other's
projects they know who to call for
different jobs because they all came up
through the same program and so I have
definitely seen that work for people
um but I think it is I think it's a
struggle for anybody film school or not
uh to get into the industry and gain the
experience and be on the list to be
hired I think it's
any which direction you come at it it's
not you know it's not an easy industry
did someone actually say to you don't
keep making films yeah uh definitely we
were told to stay with the music stay in
our lane stay what we know and I got a
letter from that friend like years later
apologizing oh that's awesome you know
it was nice because like you know now
I'm like fifth movie and I'm like no you
you know you followed your path you're
good
um you know and like another one was a
person that was in film school and was
like no it's all wrong uh one of those
people yeah but definitely my like we
went straight for music videos into a
feature film so we kind of skipped the
like learning on short film thing that a
lot of people do you know and so like
definitely we learned like you can't
have a 10 page dialogue like just
monologue for your end scene you know so
like our first film has that and it was
definitely like very boring you know
once we cut it we're like oh God like
now we know keep our dialogue a little
more Snappy you know and so like each
movie we've
tried to hone that a little bit more
keep it moving a lot faster and but like
we wouldn't have known that if we hadn't
done it you know but it's out there and
that's the thing like it was good enough
to be distributed and get out there like
10 years ago and so like it opens it up
to the criticisms
of a first time film
and you've crowdfunded three times yeah
yeah uh crowdfunding is like a journey
and so like for our early films we had a
good Community
um so my partner and I were in music in
Boston and we knew hundreds of people
doing music in Boston and when we
transitioned to film they were very
generous like yeah go make a film here's
10 bucks and so like we were able to
crowdfund I think it was like around 20
000 first three movies each you know
um which was great you know we were able
to rent mansions and rent locations and
pair crew interactors
um
would you know which is the way you want
to do it I think I never wanted to like
totally rely on a lot of favors even
though I have also
um but yeah crowdfunding is definitely
difficult it's time consuming but it
does build a good Community around you
and it makes people very invested in the
project in where it goes
um they want to see it through
uh so you know and you don't have that
kind of organic Community around a film
necessarily without that couple hundred
people's input you know
and you finish the projects right yeah
finished all of them that's important
rewards out yeah see so a lot yeah
um where does the urge to be an artist
come from I think it just goes back to
like some
narcissistic idea that I have something
to say that's a little bit different
than everybody else
um and just the urge to create like you
know I was saying earlier like I need to
be moving I need to have my hands in
something I need to be thinking about
something and I think during the
pandemic not to dwell on the pandemic
but where I wasn't working it was very
depressing you know and I just like you
know I got a dog because I was like I
can't deal with this like not having
anything to do and
um you know and I think that like kind
of put into perspective because I mean I
started working again and started
working on my own projects again I was
happy again so I think it is partially
that like I need to be creating
something just for my own mental state
to keep me going as a person
what do you think about artists who are
more talented than you but they don't
want to put in the same amount of work
because they're waiting for their work
to be discovered right um well I think I
mean what is the saying it's 99
perspiration creating anything I think
99 of it is physical labor to me it's
like getting on set knowing all the
technical stuff doing the job going into
the edit room for months and months and
months you know it is definitely like a
slog and it's work and it's like very
hard so if you don't have that work
ethic in addition to your Genius and
your talent like I don't think you're
gonna get very far unless you have money
to pay everybody to do all that other
stuff for you so I think if you have the
talent and not the drive you need some
cash
laughs
I like that that's good that's a good
little little saying but there are
people out there who are very talented
and then you see that they're just kind
of like they're they don't want to take
certain steps they don't want to try to
make contacts I get not wanting to
promote yourself you know especially in
this day and age where everybody wants
to be a quote-unquote influencer it it
kind of gets a negative rot but they
just have you seen that in people that
whether they went to film school or not
they seem like they're not willing to
put their stuff out there but you know
they're brilliant
yeah and why they why that is
um yeah you know I know like certain
friends of mine who are very talented
directors and things they're just like
waiting for that perfect storm of like I
have a good script I have the money I
have producers on board all like this
hurricane of things coming together for
them and I just feel like if you're
waiting for it to be perfect it's never
gonna happen you know so like for me
like we always have a ton of ideas ready
to go like we have our ten thousand
dollar scripts we have our million
dollar scripts and it's like if we can
just figure out what resources we have
in that moment that's the project we do
and you know but like I have like script
set in space I'll probably never be able
to make but if that was my dream project
then I would not make anything you know
so it's like I have these other ideas
I'm like okay well it's in a house with
two people like that one I can make next
week you know if I just like have the
actors on board you know and have a
location on board so I think it's really
about just diversifying where you are at
you you know as far as like what you
need to get done
um because yeah if you're waiting for
that perfect storm it might not ever
come for you
do you think it's also about being a
realist
oh yeah I'm very pragmatic yeah and
especially with like Perfection like I I
am definitely a perfectionist at heart
but I'm a perfectionist that like knows
that getting to 90 is like maybe okay
you know and because that last ten
percent is gonna take you like way
longer and way more work to get that
last 10 perfect then it got you to the
90 so if you can accept 90 you're good
just release it